despite rising costs the summer travel
season is shaping up to be a big one
travel industry booking data indicates
pre-pandemic levels of demand so what
will the travel landscape look like this
summer and how can we plan the perfect
vacation without breaking the bank
travel expert janine tornatore joins us
with the information and advice that we
could all use right now welcome janine
what destinations are expected to be big
this summer and are the rising costs
affecting where travelers are going
well
it's all about the beaches this year
this is where we're seeing a lot of the
double-digit demand places like hawaii
people are looking to those destinations
like waikiki those those classic resorts
like the
moana surf rider right there on the
beach you're also seeing that the
caribbean and mexico are seeing high
demand so people really want those beach
destinations we're also saying though
that national parks are still on the top
of everyone's list there's so much
demand for some of these popular
national parks that they're actually
requiring some of them requiring
reservations and permits just to get
into the park so you know if you want
that kind of national park outdoor
experience i like looking to places like
denver downtown denver has great hotel
availability you have great properties
like the sheridan which has a rooftop
pool a great uh right step out onto the
pedestrian mall right there but look
outside of denver 30 minutes an hour
away you have all these national park
outdoor experiences so look to those
places as an alternative if you haven't
made those reservations yet as someone
who was born and raised in denver i
couldn't agree with you more there's so
much to do out there what about
destinations that people could look at
if maybe they're on a budget
well our cities in the u.s are fantastic
options for summer travel a couple of
things places like chicago san francisco
dallas now if you're going to a city
this summer look at staying in the
business districts as opposed to those
theater shopping districts
look for
cities where you have multiple airport
options everyone's trying to save on
airfare this summer
and look to those destinations where you
can have that kind of dual experience
places like san francisco where you have
great hotels like the w right in the
financial district you can step out your
door do everything in the city but
outside the city you have great road
trips you have you know sonoma and napa
right out your door you have great beach
destinations like santa cruz you go to
near woods and see the 2 000 year old uh
you know redwood trees so those types of
destinations really offer a lot of value
excellent excellent advice janine thank
you so much for taking the time with us
it's definitely something that's on a
lot of people's minds getting out of
town thank you so much in las vegas now
we will be right back